all right so instead of reviewing a
paper today I thought I might review
this thing so this person on Twitter
posted this link to an article called
brief history of deep learning from 1943
to 2019 of machine learning knowledge
dot AI so let's look at this actually
let's look at the tweet first because
this is I just saw this the mail only
history of deep learning where you say
Alex net makes history but imagenet
doesn't because women's contributions
don't count and contributions from
anyone except for white and white
adjacent people for that matter that is
the tweet and it has 109 retweets over
400 likes and people generally agreeing
with this sentiment so the person is
expressing concerns that the this
article is only going over one
particular group of people it so let's
look at the article they basically go
over the history of neural networks of
deep learning in an algorithmic sense so
let's check it out so first we go into
neurons starting at 1943 and the
perceptron paper right here the first
back propagation algorithm from Kelly
this actually I think people like
schmidhuber would be proud as far as I
can tell this is kind of more of a
forgotten history or some of these
things are more of a forgotten history
of course Minsk is paper very famous but
here backpropagation attributed to this
paper and so on and you can see things
people like hint and only coming up
later here the Boltzmann machine
backpropagation in neural networks now
so
this as as far as I can tell it's just a
take on kind of the history of
algorithmic development and you can see
here it really is about algorithms the
algorithms behind deep learning so here
is the vanishing gradient problem the LS
TM as an architectural component deep
belief net deep belief networks then you
have GPUs for training again vanishing
gradients Alex net and ganz alphago so
we're now going a bit faster and then
the end it says Turing the Godfather's
win the Turing Award for their immense
contribution in advancements in area of
deep learning and artificial
intelligence this is a defining moment
for those who had worked relentlessly on
neural networks when the entire machine
learning community had moved away from
it in the nineteen seventies so the
article clearly is focused on
algorithmic developments in deep
learning right and that's why Alex net
is here now this person rags that Alex
net is here but imagenet isn't and
clearly you can see from the article
image net is a data set it was not made
with deep learning in mind it was simply
made as a data set it is not an
algorithmic development so ganzar here
as well right
but the celeb a isn't see for 10 isn't M
list isn't the penn treebank isn't right
so the I think we've tipped a lot of
architectural advancements here like
transformers or all kinds of all kinds
of things here but the history is
clearly about the algorithmic
developments and to reframe this it's
clearly States image and it doesn't
because women's contributions don't
count right the insinuation here
absolutely I find this to be absolutely
intellectually dishonest and they say
and contributions from anyone except for
white and white adjacent people that
matter at this point you just have to
laugh like because of course the
narrative that the person wanted to tell
was that it's
only white people that that count but
then you scroll in turn it doesn't fit
my narrative right this this this GPU is
not a white person so you to make it fit
your narrative you have to call white
edge it what is white adjacent it's like
if whatever I don't like I now call
white and but people just people just
agreeing with this I find this
absolutely disgusting and I find the
article to be okay I don't know better
but if you have a problem with I
definitely think there is miss
attribution in science throughout even
systematic but to say that image net
wasn't included because women's
contributions don't count that is just a
straight out lie and to call people
white adjacent is like how does do you
not have a bell in your head that goes
ding ding ding ding ding when you do
something like this so I find this to be
dishonest either willfully or just
because people have so become used to
seeing the world in one particular frame
and this is I think these these calls
they only get they only get big whenever
there is money and attention going into
a field right if you look at like any
any field where it's just a bunch of
weirdos doing their thing the weirdos
don't care who's there they just care
about the ideas that people have right
and I believe we should take that view
in science in general I don't care who
has the idea and these people do and I
disagree all right that was it keep
pushing back on these things if you
agree as well and keep science for ideas
Thanks